voilà c'est le temps des vacances et qui
dit vacances dit petit déplacement petit
voyage un peu de lecture aussi peut-être
qu'est-ce qui devrait faire nos députés
que devrait-il lire voyons voir ce que
mes collaborateurs en pensent alex je
commence avec vous qui on envoie en
vacances mais à quel endroit Pierre-Paul
lièvre dans tous les lieux ravagés par
les catastrophes naturelles au pays
c'est le printemps que ce soit les
inondations ou les feux de forêts et le
l'embarras du choix toutes les provinces
ou presque ont été touchées pour aller
voir un peu sur le terrain comment ça se
passe je ne vois pas comment la partie
conservateur peut aller en campagne
électorale avec un discours qui minimise
la force des changements climatiques
l'adaptation changement climatique qu'on
peut mettre la hache dans le prix sur le
carbone qu'on veut construire plus de
pépines exploiter du gaz exploiter du
pétrole
[Musique]
continuer à siéger pour réécrire le
budget Freeland ça arrivera pas mais vu
qu'il veut annuler ces vacances
peut-être qu'ils devraient plancher
lui-même sur un plan économique qui
montre comment les conservateurs ne
ramèneraient à l'équilibre budgétaire ce
qui gardait le programme de garde ce qui
mettrait fin à l'économie verte et aux
mesures incitatives est-ce que il y a
des soins dentaires ça s'en va aux
poubelles est-ce qui couperait dans la
santé on a c'est absolument rien et
d'autre part même s'il reste à maison il
va pouvoir appliquer le conseil de
d'Alec puisque avez-vous vu la boucane
cette semaine pas besoin d'aller plus
loin que le parc de la Gatineau pour
voir ce qui se passe quelque chose
climatiques qu'en temps réel
effectivement je reste avec vous et qui
dit quoi pendant ce temps là ok c'est
une drôle de suggestion mais on parle
beaucoup de d'intelligence artificielle
la classe politique est pas
particulièrement éduqué là-dessus et il
y a une députée une seule une députée
conservatrice de l'Alberta
qui elle en a fait sa spécialité et pas
dans les bonnes grâces de pierre
poillievre ou l'inverse elle en profite
pour se spécialiser là-dedans elle écrit
des textes sur substacle et vraiment
c'est de la lecture que je conseille
fortement à tout politicien qui veut
s'instruire sur cette question-là reste
une minute Michel et ensuite avec un
livre qui s'appelle King alive c'est une
nouvelle biographie de Martin Luther
King de John Newton Higg qui va sans
doute gagner rafler tous les prix pour
lui dire de ce monde c'est la vie de
Martin Luther King sous l'angle du
leadership ça serait très intéressant
pour n'importe qui veut devenir
politicien bon et Alex pour Michael
c'est bien l'heure de bien s'entourer
pour réussir en affaires parce qu'il
arrive à la tête d'Hydro-Québec avec
très peu d'expérience en matière
d'énergie il faut avoir besoin d'être
entouré il a des qualités mais il faudra
qu'il soit bien entouré pour être
capable de bien manier au Québec avec
tous les défis hydroc-québec devraient
relever dans les prochaines mais
celui-là c'est en état effectivement
c'est là-dessus que ce conclut notre
bilan de l'année c'est ainsi que se
termine aussi cette dixième saison
d'écolisses du pouvoir Alex Chantal
Michel merci d'avoir été des nôtres
encore une fois cette année au plaisir
de vous retrouver en septembre prochain
merci à tous nos collaborateurs à
Montréal Ottawa dans la station du
réseau les collègues qui nous ont permis
de produire cette émission à toutes les
semaines et merci à vous à la maison
d'avoir été des nôtres encore cette
année et si Daniel Thibault à Montréal
au nom de toute l'équipe c'est la fin de
journée bonne semaine bon été surtout et
puis au plaisir de vous retrouver en
septembre
[Musique]